quick story time before the review I had
to review six underground because Summer
2018 Vanessa and I went on vacation we
went to Florence Italy to get away from
it all unhooked no comment sections no
videos just Florence Italy and Michael
Bay was filming a movie called six
underground there what are the odds I
can't escape it he followed me there
it's really cool outside our Airbnb
there was a car chase going on it was
cool to see that in the movie it's about
in the 8 minute 45 second mark in the
movie just if you're wondering so I got
to talking about this one when it comes
out I'm attached now so now it's out
here we go
[Music]
six underground so six underground is a
Michael Bay film straight to Netflix
it's about six people who have a
particular set of skills
all of them are presumed dead though
obviously they're alive they're doing
this underground their ghosts led by
Ryan Reynolds who's a super rich guy
I've got them all together and yes this
is totally Avengers meets Knight Rider
now that I'm explaining it and now
they're gonna do a regime change take
out this tyrant replace him with his
brother yes it is Avengers meets Knight
Rider meets man in the iron mask Michael
Bay and in the first half for this movie
I was like okay this is actually a text
that I texted I think it's pretty
accurate myself and a rotten tomatoes is
always looking for the phrase to put on
Rotten Tomatoes from my review of the
movie so tomatoes if you're watching can
we make my quote 600 ground is like
doing a line of coke while
simultaneously doing a cake stand of Red
Bull up your ass I think that's just
accurate I think I'm putting to rest
whether or not my channel is made for
children
I don't think YouTube's ever has asked
me that again but if kids are watching
hugs not drugs don't do that that's
terrible the first half is so just
you're like oh action scene action scene
action sequence upon action sequence is
it disjointed yes is it stylistic
actually the thing I enjoyed about it is
the fact that it's just the deaths what
can I say stylistic cinematic death well
that's just fun and whether it's a car
smashing into something on its side
splitting the [ __ ] half a car
smashing into something and there's like
now a dead body on that something or
someone flying out of a car and then
getting sucked under the tire I'm just
saying Michael Bay was just like alright
I have a budget I have an R rating I
have no one looking over my shoulder I'm
all for directors being able to give
their vision Michael Bay is just one of
those guys that I've seen where I'm like
you probably should have some coin
look let's make something cohesive the
first 20 minutes of this movie action
sequence why they're running they just
are there they are because they are
because Bay that's Bay not Bay and after
that you get the flashbacks of the
people to see how they joined the crew
and at one point Ryan Reynolds was like
alright now you're all cut up also one
more flashback sequence I was like I
thought we were caught up the second
half of the movie you know after the
first hour that's when the movies like
alright we're focusing up and we're
actually here to do the job
the a-team slash nightriders slash
Avengers are here to do the man in the
iron mask thing not really man in the
iron mask I mean they're not identical
that doesn't matter so the second half
of the movies actually a lot more
enjoyable because it's actually a
storyline happen with storyline nothing
but it's cohesive it's actually one
thing leads to the next leads
the next okay you can fall away you
can't follow [ __ ] in the first hour of
this movie just it's just stuff
happening but even then it's just like
people are still kooky weird versions of
themselves like Ryan Reynolds is Ryan
Reynolds but everyone else just kind of
like this is one scene where they're
like alright we're using laughing gas
and everyone's laughing and one guy's
like oh I lost part of my mask he so now
I'm laughing so they have to deal with
that now I always feel like Michael Bay
makes these changes on set you know
where he was like I'm just gonna have an
action sequence but what if someone
actually got hit with the laughing gas
who was actually a part of the team it's
like sam witwicky 'he's mom and
Transformers Revenge of the Fallen which
I've only seen once in theaters but this
is a scene I remember mostly she ate the
pot brownie it's like Michael Bay filmed
that scene with Sam Witwicky SMAW man he
was like one day I'm gonna have someone
act like that in another movie only
they're gonna have a gun and it's gonna
be an action sequence because why not
the movies messy all the high-octane
chase sequences near the beginning is
fun but in that YouTube kind of way I
feel like there could just be a string
of YouTube videos a playlist called car
chases no story and just a montage of
chase sequences and you'll just kind of
get the same feeling and then cool
military stuff no story alright that's
the other part of the first half of this
movie as a whole this movies just
detached and just feels like people
through remnants of a plotline on a wall
and they just connected strings and
they're like wow doesn't all make sense
fact most of it doesn't but what does
what's film it there was some really
stylistic stuff that was happening near
the end of this movie involving a magnet
I can't deny that there was also a
horrendous amount of shaky-cam in the
second half - so there you are and
imperfectly balanced [ __ ] how the
whole thing should be you've heard the
phrase all style no substitutes I don't
even know how good the style is cuz in
terms of style it's not that stylish I
think a style I think of something sleek
and polished you know boned James Bolton
this is like this boards bro James PAH I
don't know style over substance is the
phrase but I will say six underground
would probably be a better time if I
were drunk yeah that case there was the
Red Bull alright so six underground have
you seen it what did you think about it
whatever you thought comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you seen here and you want to see more
click right here to see more
[Music]